deuil national de quatre jours youri
andropov ancien chef du kgb chargé de
présider la commission des funérailles
ce qui le place en bonne position pour
la succession
la prochaine libération de lech walesa
c'est le gouvernement polonais il a lui
même annoncé tout à l'heure
enfin lancement réussi pour la navette
spatiale columbia
ce sera son premier vol commercial de
cinq jours autour de la terre nous avons
la profonde douleur de faire part aussi
youm et à tout le peuple
la mort subite de leonid il est servir
les ministres est ce c'est ce soir c'est
donc ainsi que la population soviétique
qui a été informé ce matin à 9 heures
heure de paris de la mort de son chef
leonid ilitch brejnev décédés de mort
subite à l'âge de 75 ans hier mais le
comité central du parti communiste
soviétique a tenu la nouvelle secrète
pendant 24 heures un peu plus tard on
apprenait que le deuil serait de quatre
jours que le corps du président sera
exposée à partir de demain à la maison
des syndicats et que ses obsèques
pourraient donc avoir lieu lundi
leonid brejnev sera inhumé sur la place
rouge une nouvelle à laquelle à vrai
dire on s'attendait depuis longtemps ce
qui explique peut-être la relative
indifférence de la population soviétique
ce soir il est bien
à la télévision soviétique ce soir après
20 minutes de biographies de leonid
brejnev lui par un speaker sans la
moindre image la télévision a diffusé ce
soir l'annoncé de la mort de leonid
brejnev aux ouvriers des usines
l'impression après ce premier reportage
est celle de la réserve et aussi de la
tristesse de ce qu'il a gouverné pendant
18 ans pour l'ensemble des soviétiques 7
à 9 heures heure de paris qu'ils
apprenaient la mort des lots ni brejnev
par un communiqué lu à la radio
ces images tournées à moscou ce matin
sont celles d'une ville où commence à se
propager la nouvelle les tout premiers
signes de deuil sont les drapeaux des
bâtiments officiels que l'on commence
tout juste à mettre en berne
plus tard dans la journée il n'y a pas
eu beaucoup de réactions extérieur rien
de commun avec ce qui a suivi la mort de
joseph staline
aujourd'hui les autorités n'ont pas jugé
utile de lancer des appels au calme
il faut dire que la population
s'attendait à être informés de la mort
d'un haut dignitaire
il n'y a pas eu de surprise toute la
journée d'hier les radios ont diffusé de
la musique classique les présentateurs
de la télévision étaient habillés de
noir tandis que d'importantes rencontres
sportives et des spectacles de variétés
n'était pas retransmis sur les antennes
dans l'après midi l'agent stas la radio
et la télévision diffusait une
déclaration du comité central du pc et
du présidium du soviet suprême saluant
je cite la mémoire du glorieux fils de
la classe ouvrière et toutes les
ambassades à l'étranger
prenez le deuil par exemple ici à paris
où l'on ouvrait un registre de
condoléances l'ambassade sera ouverte à
tous à partir de demain mais aujourd'hui
à 52 délégations de partis frères ici
maxime gremetz pour le pcf et deux
ambassades étrangères se sont rendus à
l'ambassade soviétique
à paris quelques minutes à peine après
la diffusion officielle de la nouvelle
charles hernu le ministre français de la
défense qui participaient aux cérémonies
du 11 novembre
apprenez cette disparition à l'attaché
militaire soviétique à paris regardez
bien le trouble et l'émotion du
diplomate
je viens d'apprendre à marcher
libre à genève vient de mourir et je
voudrais vous présenter tamponné de la
défense toutes les condoléances
pour le ministre
initiatique pour votre de leur monnaie
jean-claude rians des dépenses français
des armées
je suis
pour ceux qui
hier soir nous faisions état dans ce
journal de rumeurs persistantes à moscou
sur la mort d'un haut dirigeant mais on
pensait alors qu'il se disait monsieur
kirilenko des rumeurs sur une
disparition de brainiac lui-même se
multipliaient depuis sept ans depuis le
début de sa malvy mais curieusement les
dernières images que nous avions reçu de
lui et diffuser je pense que vous en
souvenez dans notre journal de dimanche
dimanche soir donnait l'impression d'un
homme en meilleure santé
c'était à l'occasion des cérémonies
marquant le 65e anniversaire de la
révolution de 1917
il va sans dire que l'essentiel de ce
journal sera consacré à cette
disparition puis à la libération dans
les jours à venir de lech walesa
de plus tout de suite après cette
édition une spéciale brejnev avec de
nombreux invités autour de christine
ockrent et de georges bortoli une
spéciale qui remplace l'heure de vérité
consacrée à marie france garaud qui fera
quand même partie de ses invités par
ailleurs vous le voyez la formule svp
conservez donc à partir de maintenant
vous pouvez appeler philippe harrouard
et svp 11 ans pour poser des questions
sur la mort de lénine est fait sur ses
conséquences
mais avant de nous interroger sur les
conséquences de cette disparition
rappelons qui fut l'homme qui depuis
dix-huit ans tenait en main les rênes de
l'urss
un général de 38 ans voilà l'image de
leonid brejnev à la fin de la guerre un
général politique puisqu'il appartient à
ce qu'on appelle en urss la direction
politique des armées c'est à dire qu'il
s'occupe de l'encadrement morale et
idéologique des soldats et des officiers
on le voit ainsi sur les fronts du
caucase et d'ukraine les fronts sud de
la guerre lui même d'ailleurs état
méridional
il est né en ukraine c'est à dire le
midi de l'union soviétique et il y à
exercer ses premières responsabilités
civile au sein du parti communiste
ukrainien en juin 1945
ils participent à la parade de la
victoire à moscou sur la place rouge il
ya ainsi dans les armées soviétiques des
généraux qui ont beaucoup d'avenir comme
le général khrouchtchev et le général
brejnev beaucoup d'avenir puisque en
1960 le voici président du présidium du
soviet suprême une sorte le président de
la république mais à l'époque sans grand
pouvoir se contentant de décerner des
décorations et de recevoir les visiteurs
officiels sociable volontiers jovial il
soutient mordicus les mérites de la
cigarette ruche devant fidel castro
plutôt amateur de cigares on dit de lui
qu'il aime la bonne chère et aussi les
longues parties de chasse dans les
solitudes neigeuse de la forêt russe
en fait on le connaît mal encore mais en
octobre 1964 à 57 ans c'est l'ascension
fulgurante
il devient le premier secrétaire du
parti le numéro un du régime celui vers
qui convergent les regards et les
acclamations lors des grandes
manifestations de la place rouge
son pouvoir se renforce d'année en année
devient de plus en plus personnel et de
ce pouvoir il fait d'abord dans les
années 60 et 70 un usage que les
occidentaux apprécié puisqu'il se
présente comme l'homme de la détente 2
1972 à 1974 il entame avec richard nixon
une politique de rapprochement actifs
accord sur le désarmement projets de
coopération économique de mise en valeur
de la sibérie tout y passe
nixon espère couvrir par ses succès de
politique étrangère la rumeur gronde en
du watergate brejnev et satisfait
d'imposer son pays comme le deuxième
grand sur un pied d'égalité nucléaire
fraternisation excitante maladroite qui
sera vite déçu par la reprise de la
course aux armements une époque tout de
même dans cette oeuvre de décrispation
internationale la france avait une bonne
longueur d'avancé dès 1970 georges
pompidou était à moscou pour y
poursuivre selon le triptyque gaullien
la détente l'entente et la coopération
des rapports fréquents suivi presque
institutionnels ça marchait alors entre
le kremlin et l'elysée et jusqu'en 1979
on allait voir les présidents pompidou
puis giscard d'estaing se rendre
régulièrement à une mére cesse et le
secrétaire général soviétique se rendre
non moins régulièrement au château de
rambouillet
le commerce franco soviétique doubler
tous les cinq ans paris et moscou
s'étaient mis à coopérer dans bien des
domaines y compris ceux de la recherche
nucléaire et de la recherche spatiale
à la fin 2009 179 ses bons rapports
franco soviétique était brutalement
refroidis par l'invasion de
l'afghanistan qui se tenait en même
temps le glas de la détente
on n'a plus revu depuis leonid brejnev à
paris alors qu'en six ans il y était
venu quatre fois mais à moscou le gel
d'un régime de plus en plus pesant de
cette pesanteur un symbole l'armée
puissante honoré doter le crédit énorme
prends tu as s'autocélébrer dans les
obsèques de ses chefs glorieux leonid
brejnev avait bien le droit d'être au
premier rang aux funérailles du maréchal
joukov
figure de proue de l'urss militaire
cedar mais il l'a voulu il l'a appuyé de
tout son poids
sous brejnev les généraux soviétiques
ont pesé le plus en plus lourd dans le
monde
de l'afghanistan à cuba de l'angola à
l'ethiopie
et c'est l'armée soviétique encore qui a
mis à mort le printemps de
tchécoslovaquie en 1968 un printemps
dont voici les derniers feux
dix-huit jours après le baiser de
brejnev du tchèque
les charges billettique entreront dans
prague ainsi sera mis fin à toute cette
joie à tous ses rêves de renouveau
libéral en europe de l'est
la normalisation à l'extérieur va de
pair avec la normalisation intérieur les
dissidents soviétiques sont poursuivis
emprisonnés ou encore exil était un
soljenitsyne arrivant à zurich en 1974
exil à l'étranger pour jénine exil
intérieur pour sakharov autre prix nobel
prison camp de concentration asile
psychiatrique pour des milliers d'autres
coupables d'avoir voulu penser parler
agir librement et réduisent au silence
quand ils ne sont pas chassés hors de
l'union soviétique
quant aux polonais pour réprimer leur
choix de liberté pour réduire leur
courage indomptable
moscou a donné carte blanche à un homme
qu'elle considère comme sur le général
jaruzelski dont la presse soviétique a
salué le coup d'état camao fait le voici
d'ailleurs accueilli en héros par un
brejnev fatigué et comme absents
fatigué oui le brejnev des années 80 ne
ressemble plus guère au fringant
chasseurs des années 60 lorsque les
devoirs de sa charge l'amène à
l'étranger on le voit se forçant
visiblement pour participer aux
cérémonies officielles la démarche
pénible le souffle court
il faut alléger ses programmes à
l'extrême espaces et ces rendez vous ici
à bonn en novembre 80 il a 74 ans il en
paraît davantage
visiblement affaibli par une maladie sur
laquelle moscou observe un silence total
mais la télévision soviétique le montre
souvent le geste rare élan le visage
ravagé
qu'elle le montre ici éclatante en longs
sanglots aux obsèques du général gros
chez voir son ami de jeunesse
il continue d'accumuler les titres et
les dignité il est chef de l'état
secrétaire général du parti
maréchal de l'union soviétique président
du conseil de défense et à dire chef
suprême des armées
ces ouvrages sont publiés à 65 millions
d'exemplaires la presse l'entourent d'un
véritable tube qu'il est couvert
dommages et de louanges
mais l'on chuchote qu'il ne peut
travailler que deux ou trois jours par
semaine et l'on se demande si toute
cette puissance
il exerce vraiment ou s'il est le porte
parole d'une direction plus collégiale
qu'il ne semble devenu peut-être un
symbole dans un pays qui a fait du
symbole un moyen le gouvernement
l'homme nous l'avons dit était malade
depuis sept ans mais sa première
défaillance remonté après 20 ans un
accident du coeur et un homme et pied
tous ces comportements depuis très
longtemps
l'auteur de ces malades qui nous
gouvernent le président soviétique
souffrait d'une artériosclérose ainsi
généralisé qui l'a touché d'abord hooker
il a fait plusieurs infarctus une carte
depuis 1968 des troubles du rythme
cardiaque avec des chutes de pression
des malaises des vertiges important et
c'est un indice 975 exactement qu'on a
fait intervention pour lui poser un
pacemaker c'est-à-dire un stimulateur
cardiaque
par la suite la sauce perron that les le
cerveau les artères cérébrales et il a
fait ce qu'on appelle une maladie
d'alvarez c'est à dire de tout petit
micro embolie qui n'ont pas fait une
grosse attaque avec perte de la parole
ou perdre l'usagé des membres mais de
nouveau une atténuation de l'activité
cérébrale une difficulté de l'allocution
qui était très nette et une difficulté
dans la démarche enfin une perte
certaine de la puissance intellectuelle
au point qu'ils ne pouvaient assister
que 1h 1h30 à certaine confiance qui
était prévue pour trois ou quatre heures
constamment les médecins s'occupaient de
lui faut dire qu'elle est libre et nef
était un homme qui aimait bien la vie et
qui ne se refuser ni talent ni tabac ni
alcool et à titre d'anecdote écouter
juste cette brève conversation qu'il
avait eue un jour avec léon zitrone un
seul unien c'est un porte cigarette
aspect habituel je n'ai à l'intérieur un
mécanisme indicateurs si je le mets sur
une heure je ne peux pas ouvrir le porte
cigarettes avant qu'une heure se soit
écoulé
mais heureusement j'ai tad c'est
seulement après une heure qu'il s'ouvre
et que ce soit près d'une cigarette et
suit mais ça me permet de limiter la
consommation de cigarettes
les derniers temps avant mon voyage en
france et même ici j'ai pu me miner une
zone limitée à 10 7 cigarettes par jour
alors qu avant j'en fumais 30 hellemmes
35 15 jours
cela dit qu'il connaissait bien disait
qu'il avait trouvé plus d'un stratagème
pour doubler sa consommation de tabac et
ne pas se servir que de son étui mais
c'est fait qu'un clin d'oeil parlons
maintenant des problèmes de l'avenir
tous les spécialistes le disent pas de
tournant politique majeur à attendre
dans l'immédiat
l'intérim sera assuré par le président
du conseil des ministres monsieur
nicolas konnov et par le vice président
du soviet suprême vassilikos medsoft
mais l'important c'est demain et là deux
hommes se disputent la succession
messieurs andropov et crâniens qu
alexandre adler évaluer les choses il
deux seulement en raison des fonctions
qu'ils occupent le premier constantine
gustino beach tchernenko a longtemps été
le secrétaire particulier de brejnev
il apparaît comme le numéro deux dans la
hiérarchie l'autre du ried ladmirault
vichan report a longtemps dirigé le tagi
b c'est-à-dire la police politique
il est depuis le printemps secrétaire du
comité central qui est chamane
correctement kirienko qui a fait toute
sa carrière à l'ombre de brejnev et
l'homme de l'appareil du parti
c'est à dire qu'il a avec lui tous ceux
qui veulent voir dans le parti la
première force de l'union soviétique et
que cette force le reste
bien sûr cela suppose aussi certains
éléments militaires et politiques qui
ont toujours été hostile à des réformes
et à la détente et andropov baal inverse
un drop or qui joue un peu à contre
emploi puisque en france on voit en lui
le premier policier l'union soviétique
s'est identifié depuis des années à
certains courants réformateurs
sur le plan intérieur économie et sur le
plan extérieur notamment par une
approche nouvelle des relations avec la
chine et l'europe occidentale qui va
l'emporter
eh bien sans qu'on puisse faire de
pronostics sur on peut remarquer qu'en
europe on a été chargée d'organiser les
obsèques de
brejnev ce qui est un très grand honneur
et que au même moment on apprend qu'en
pologne
on envisage la libération vous combien
taux de lettres jens et vous voyez un
rapport entre les deux à mon avis ces
deux signes vont à l'encontre de ce
qu'on avait observé depuis septembre à
dire un durcissement dans tous les
domaines qui semblaient maîtres andropov
en échec il aurait peut-être donc un
coup de théâtre qui est en train de se
produire
évoquons maintenant les réactions les
plus rapides et les plus attristées ont
été celles des pays de l'est mais à
pékin on a également été moins lent qu'à
l'accoutumée l' agence chine nouvelle
tout comme la télévision vont annoncer
le décès sans commentaire vous voyez
d'ailleurs ici la façon dont ce décès a
été annoncé mais il est sûr que la
nouvelle a été ressenti assez
brutalement le dialogue entre moscou et
pékin venait à peine d'être renouer
deuxième capitale directement intéressés
washington le président afghan doit
tenir une conférence de presse dans
quelques heures mais il a d'ores et déjà
adressé ses condoléances aux autorités
soviétiques en faisant part de son désir
d'améliorer les relations entre
washington et moscou et loir laure au
téléphone
la première réaction officielle en
provenance de washington est tombé à
quelques instants avec la lecture du
message de condoléances envoyé par
ronald reagan au responsable logistique
contre monsieur le président je compte
conduire les relations avec la nouvelle
direction soviétique dans le seul but
d'étendre les secteurs où the pipe
entendre extrême prudence de la maison
blanche sans doute motivée par l'état
des relations washington moscou
si l'on fait que se dégrader depuis
l'arrivée de ronald reagan au pouvoir
depuis donc deux ans qui a fait que
ronald reagan aurait été le seul setrag
gagné présidents américains à n'avoir
jamais rencontré léonid brejnev n'est
pas certain en tout cas que ronald
reagan détermine plus clairement dans
quelques heures
dans sa conférence de presse prévue
depuis toujours
compte tenu du fait que les américains
font comme tout le monde
attendre maintenant le voir ce qu'il se
passe à moscou même autre message de
condoléances celui qu'a dressé le
président mitterrand au présidium du
soviet suprême le rôle éminent de l'ailé
brejnev dans le monde sera retenue dans
l'histoire dit le chef de l'état
français
et ce à un moment important où les
relations entre paris et moscou traversé
des périodes de froid mais écoutez
depuis l'arrivée de françois mitterrand
au pouvoir
c'est très simple il n'y a pas ou peu de
relation un très haut niveau entre la
france et l'union soviétique alors
schématiquement cette absence de
relation on peut dire même ce
refroidissement considérable des
relations depuis le 10 mai 1981 tient à
trois raisons essentielles
la première de ces raisons c'est
l'afghanistan bien sûr de nombreuses
fois avant et après son élection
françois mitterrand a affirmé qu'il ne
pouvait avoir de bonnes relations entre
moscou et la france tant que l'armée
rouge occuperait le sol afghan
deuxième de ces raisons la pologne le
gouvernement français a très clairement
mis en cause la politique soviétique
dans la sphère polonaise
là je vous rappelle le deux déclarations
qui m'a plus importante ces derniers
mois à propos de la pologne
l'une de pierre mauroy je le cite qui
dénoncé l'ingérence réel de l'urss dans
la situation polonaise une autre de
françois mitterrand
tout ce qui permettra de sortir de yalta
sera bon alors troisième raison
essentielle l' équilibre stratégique là
encore le chef de l'état a maintes fois
dénoncé le rôle stratégique des fusées
et le danger que faisait courir l'union
soviétique en mettant l'installant sur
consoles les fameuses fusée ss20 vous
comprendrez aisément que dans ce climat
le président de la république a déjà
rencontré tous les grands leaders de ce
monde n'est pas jugé bon de rendre
visite aux dirigeants soviétiques bien
sûr il le fera dans quelques jours dans
quelques mois mais je crois au moment où
il le jugera important avec quand même
une petite satisfaction pour moscou dans
ce tableau assez sombre des relations
l'accord signé il ya quelques mois par
la france sur la construction du gazoduc
euros sibérien et bien sûr la politique
de la france de ne pas suivre les états
unis dans leur politique de sanctions à
l'égard de l'union soviétique et pour le
ps lionel jospin et tout à l'heure et à
des contradictions de la politique
intérieure et extérieure de l'urss
depuis 20 ans jacques chirac a fait de
même en disant tout imaginé un vestiaire
il a fait dans le monde mais qui fut
aussi le l'implacable représentant d'un
système totalitaire
jean lecanuet pour l'udf estime que
l'urss reste une dictature dans l'ordre
extérieures dit il impérialisme et
expansionnisme ont été les maîtres mots
de la politique de monsieur brejnev mais
la déclaration la plus attendue peut
être épais
du parti communiste français qui a lui
salué la volonté de paix de léonie
bréviaire dans un monde tumultueux
marquée par de vastes bouleversements
les peuples en lutte pour la libération
nationale sociales et humaines ont
trouvé en leonid brejnev compréhension
et solidarité
son expérience personnelle et
l'expérience vécue par son peuple
aussi bien que l'idéal communiste lui
avais inculqué la haine de la guerre
tous ceux qui l'ont approché savent à
quel point sa pensée et son action était
dominée par la volonté de paix leonid
brejnev a pris part conclut on nous à
l'établissement de rapports nouveau
entre nos deux partis
sur cette base nous renouvelons à nos
camarades soviétique l'assurance de nos
sentiments de solidarité
internationaliste dans la lutte pour la
paix l'indépendance nationale le progrès
social
le socialisme nous exprimons au parti
communiste de l'union soviétique au
peuple soviétique notre sympathie
sincère devant le deuil qui les frappe
à noter enfin cette déclaration d'alain
krivine
contrairement aux hypocrites de tous
bords nous n'aurons pas une larme et pas
d'un regret pour le bourreau de prague
de kaboul ou de varsovie notre pensée
aujourd'hui va'a vers tous ceux qui
croupissent dans les camps et les
hôpitaux psychiatriques avec vous
georges bortoli six ans maintenant de de
soupeser un petit peu les chances de la
détente en cette fin d'année 82 car
c'est bien ce soir la question
essentielle qui nous préoccupe
oui mais vous savez que
traditionnellement les périodes
successorale en urss sont des périodes
de détente l'exemple classique staline
mort en 1953 en pleine guerre froide
très dur et immédiatement ses
successeurs joue la détente
autre exemple crouch off et limogés en
1964 est immédiatement ses successeurs
d'ombré génère qui dit à l'époque que
l'un des membres de la direction
collégiale joue là des temps c'est
logique s'ils voulaient tant que la
question de la succession n'est pas
vraiment réglé tant que le pouvoir n'est
pas tenue vraiment en main par quelqu'un
tant qu'il ya donc un flottement au
sommet on est
et à prendre des risques si vous voulez
on peut donc faire l'hypothèse que cette
fois aussi nous la période successorale
qui peut être assez longue ce sera aussi
une période de détente est tout de même
un correctif c'est que l'armée depuis
quelques années a pris un grand poids
qu'il ya un bloc de pression politico
militaire et que ce bloc peut exiger du
candidat à la place de numéro un une
grande fermeté vis-à-vis de l'occident
alors de toute façon il ya quelque chose
qui va changer parce que vous avez bien
vu ces derniers temps la politique
étrangère de l'urss était devenu très
statique très essoufflée très
vieillissante les marches de son chef
malade et vieillissant maintenant
théoriquement des nouvelles initiatives
sont possibles y compris peut-être des
rencontres entre les dirigeants
soviétiques et les dirigeants
occidentaux alors que les rapports
étaient jusqu'à présent presque
complètement gelé il est vrai aussi que
le nom et les briefe restera toujours
les lier à ce que l'on a appelé la
doctrine de la souveraineté limitée des
pays socialistes qui a été évoqué pour
la première fois à l'occasion
d'interventions la tchécoslovaquie en 68
et puis plus tard en afghanistan
l'afghanistan qui restera pour la
plupart des occidentaux
une tâche difficilement effaçable sur
l'uniforme soviétique patricia jean
nolet
trois ans après l'invasion de
l'afghanistan par l'armée rouge c'était
en décembre 1979
les soldats soviétiques des soldats
afghans des résistants et des civils
afghans meurt toujours par centaines
sinon par milliers l'opinion
internationale les capitales
occidentales
les chefs d'états proteste encore contre
cette invasion
la durée de cette guerre bourbier
l'ampleur des réactions deux
conséquences que n'avait pas prévu
leonid brejnev
il ne pensait pas non plus que cette
affaire bloquerait à ce point le
dialogue avec ronald reagan et durcir et
autant les relations avec de très
nombreux pays dont la france
conséquence également sur le plan
intérieur soviétique
l'ampleur de l'aide qui avaient été
apportées à babrak karmal commencé à
être contestées officieusement à moscou
l'invasion de l'afghanistan a donc
marqué les limites et même souligner les
impasses de la diplomatie soviétique un
retrait des troupes
aurais tu étais l'aveu de l'échec de
même la résistance afghane a servi de
leçon dirigeants du kremlin et expliquer
en partie leur prudence vis-à-vis de la
bonne heure en tout cas la morgue leonid
brejnev ne devrait pas dans les mois qui
viennent boule verte et la politique
soviétique à kaboul
radio kaboul qui ne fait pas dans la
nuance vient ce soir de dire que le
peuple d'afghanistan chérira toujours la
mémoire du président projectif nous ne
serions pas complet bien sûr ce rapide
bilan de l'ère brejnev si nous parlions
de la dissidence phénomène qui s'est
beaucoup développée ces dernières années
avec une répression féroce georges
bortoli disais tout à l'heure la plupart
des dissidents estiment d'ailleurs que
cette disparition de sange rap à grand
chose
un test on le verra bien dans les mois à
venir le sort réservé à l'académicien
sakharov sakharov le père de la bombe
atomique russe aujourd'hui exilé est en
résidence surveillée depuis trois ans à
gorki andreï sakharov reste le symbole
de la dissidence
le phénomène nouveau en union soviétique
qui a marqué dans son ensemble l'ère
brejnev dès le début c'est l'exemple
soljenitsyne celui qui témoignait du
goulag sous khrouchtchev et déchu sous
brejnev disant d'embûches de toutes
sortes pour finir expulsés
ce sont aussi les procès daniel et signe
à skis deux écrivains qui en refusant de
se reconnaître coupable donne le signal
de la lutte ouverte d'intellectuels
contre le système soviétique
contestation contre laquelle est employé
l'internement psychiatrique la prison
quand ce n'est pas pour les plus connus
l'expulsion et le retrait de la
citoyenneté
andrei sakharov académiciens et savants
men longtemps de l'intérieur un combat
collectif pour la réforme démocratique
défense des opprimés tatar juifs
religieux
il créé en 1970 le comité de la défense
des droits de l'homme en urss il né en
1975 de grands espoirs dans la
conférence d'helsinki
des milliers de juifs soviétiques
avaient réussi à émigrer vers l'occident
et israël dans le début des années 70
aujourd'hui encore un atelier sharansky
juifs et soviétique fait une grève de la
faim dans le camp où il est emprisonné
pour des années afin d'obtenir une
visite de sa famille voilà l'essentiel
de ce que nous pouvions dire sur
l'événement ce soir je vous rappelle que
tout de suite après journal vous aurez
rendez vous pour une édition spéciale
avec hélène carrère d'encausse marie
france garaud il s'attendre aux invités
français soviétique au tour de christine
ockrent et le georges bortoli mais il
est aussi ce soit un autre événement
peut être d'ailleurs plus en rapport
qu'on ne le croit avec le premier la
libération prochaine de l'est
je fais les a c'est sûr maintenant et
tout à fait officielle le président de
solidarité à internet depuis 11 mois
sera libéré dans les jours à venir le
porte parole du gouvernement l'annoncé
en lisant une lettre de lech walesa
lui-même question marie mono la
libération prochaine donc de lech walesa
fait suite à une lettre qu'il a fait
parvenir au général géré aux hells qui
dans laquelle il lui propose une
rencontre et une discussion sérieuse sur
des sujets d'intérêt mutuel
le porte parole du gouvernement polonais
a précisé que le président du syndicat
solidarité n'a pas été contraint de
signer de quelconque déclaration
les valaisans avaient été arrêtés à
gdansk en décembre 80 peu avant l'assaut
de l'annnonce de la proclamation d'un
état de siège
cette décision est survenue après la
journée de grèves et de manifestations
organisée hier par solidarité et il n'a
eu qu'un faible écho parmi les ouvriers
la tournure de ces événements prouvent
selon les observateurs que la libération
de lège vallée d'aure n'est pas sans
comporter de risques pour le
gouvernement
à moins qu'ils entendent procéder à des
négociations avec le leader de
solidarité interrogés les enfants de
vallée d'aure nous proposons aux
miracles
madame valaisanne a précisé qu'elle y
croira haut lorsque lèche sera de retour
à la maison
et puis oui en ce moment même une
manifestation à varsovie dix mille
manifestants et la ministe dû faire état
de jets de grenades lacrymogènes pour
disperser ces manifestants
en bref toujours à l'étranger
l'arrestation de deux terroristes
ouest-allemand très recherchés à
francfort la démission du gouvernement
italien de monsieur spadolini démission
refusée par le président cartignies et
puis un très gros attentat tir au sud
liban contre le quartier général de
l'armée israélienne la voix du liban et
fait état d'une cinquantaine de victimes
morts ou blessés
et puis en france bien sûr les
cérémonies traditionnelles du 11
novembre
c'était aujourd'hui le 64e anniversaire
de
l'armistice patrick lecocq à paris le
chef de l'état est arrivé à 10h50 sur la
place charles-de-gaulle à l'étoile après
avoir remonté les champs elysées
accueillis par le gouverneur militaire
de paris
monsieur françois mitterrand va tout
d'abord passer les troupes en revue
comme chaque année les grandes écoles
militaires sont bien présentes les le
ministre de la défense charles hernu
avait tenu en outre à la présence des
principaux régimes en ayant participé et
participe encore à des missions
d'interposition au liban soit dans le
cadre de l'onu soit comme force
d'interposition à beyrouth parachutiste
et légionnaires étaient donc là autour
de la place de l'étoile
mais il y avait aussi les marins et les
aviateurs force matérialisant la
politique française de présence
d'équilibré de paix dans le monde
un symbole en ce 11 novembre
à l'issue de cette revue des troupes
monsieur françois mitterrand allait
déposer une gerbe sur la dalle sacré qui
abrite la dernière demeure du soldat
inconnu
après avoir signé le livre d'or et
saluer les anciens combattants qui
s'étaient regroupées très nombreux sous
l'arc de triomphe de l'étoile
et comme le veut maintenant la tradition
le président de la république en décor
dix anciens combattants de la grande
guerre
ensuite le cortège officiel descendra
les champs elysées pour s'arrêter devant
la statue de georges clemenceau hommage
aux tigres au vainqueur de 14 18 le
dépôt d'une gerbe devant la statue de
clemenceau devait mettre fin ce matin
aux cérémonies à paris à la
commémoration de ce 11 novembre 1982
mais je pense là mitterrand peu avant
midi regagner le palais de l'elysée
valéry giscard d'estaing insisté lui à
une cérémonie en alsace dans le petit
village de burnhaupt le haut à l'issue
d'une visite de trois jours dans la
région
et puis à la fin de l'une de ces
cérémonies du 11 novembre
marcel paul pris d'un malaise succombait
marcel-paul vous le savez c'est cet
ancien ministre communiste
tout de suite après la libération qui a
mis sur pied le sait depuis le df et qui
était très populaire parmi les
sympathisants du pcf il avait 82 ans et
avait joué un rôle essentiel
pendant la résistance la france a dit
georges marchais perd une grande figure
de son mouvement ouvrier
enfin dernier sujet en images ce journal
le départ de la navette columbia pour un
vol commercial de cinq jours départ
réussi jean ziegler et oui cap canaveral
10 secondes avant le décollage
et voilà avec une régularité d'horloge
colombien s'élèvent pour la cinquième
fois de sa courte histoire cette fois ci
ce n'est plus un vol de mise au point
c'est effectivement la première mission
commerciale qui commence
montez impeccable mais les fusées
latéral selon les premières
constatations ont poussé la navette un
peu plus faiblement que prévu à bord le
commandant seven springs avec le pilote
beau robert mayer ils vont procéder à la
séparation des fusées d'appoint
voilà nous sommes à 50 km d'altitude
regardez les fusées se séparent
alors qu'il est la navette se trouve à
300 km de la terre l'équipage a déjà
déjeuné et la soute que voici est
ouverte dans ces boîtes rondes que vous
découvrez maintenant au fond de la soute
les voilà deux satellites l'un d'entre
eux sera largué dans une heure environ
ce sera le premier lancement de
satellite effectué par la nouvelle
il sera suivi par ces caméras qui
suivront également la sortie des deux
scientifiques joe allen et william le
noir dimanche soir beaucoup de
nouveautés donc pour cette première
mission commerciale commencé aujourd'hui
et tout au long des jours qui suivent
nous vous montrerons ces événements
nouveaux qui sont vraiment le symbole de
l'industrialisation d'un nouveau
continent notre planète
la banlieue spatiale de doigts des
sports avant de passer à la météo en
tennis en est le conte continue il a
battu au tournoi de wembley l'américain
brian teacher 6-3 1-0 abandon au
deuxième tour et il rencontrera
peut-être autour ce prochain mac n roses
qui serait tout à fait intéressant dans
la perspective de la finale de la coupe
davis la route du rhum est bien toujours
l'hécatombe l'anglais robert james qui
est en tête abandonne tout comme anna
l'abbé marc pajot est désormais en tête
eric tabary a pris un curieux qu'à pau
nord-est en rugby
l'argentine a battu les barbarians
français le 22 à 8
et enfin en hippisme il fallait jouer le
4 le 5 le 7 et le 10 pas de combinaison
pas de rapport pour l'instant dans notre
les régionales hervé claude voulait
donnera la météo maintenant avec alain
gillot-pétré c'est très simple pour
demain sur la méditerranée c'est du beau
temps toute la journée puis sur le reste
du pays une zone nuageuse avec de la
pluie traversera le du nord ouest au sud
est précédé d'un ciel variable est
suivie d'un ciel variable avec encore
quelques averses sur les côtes de la
manche les températures quant à elles
sont sans changement par rapport à
aujourd'hui minimum 13 degrés au nord
maximum 20 degrés à ajaccio lors puisque
c'est la même chose passons l'éphéméride
demain vendredi 12 novembre quatre
minutes de soleil en moins levé 7h56
coucher 17h13 et celle à 5 questions
voilà donc à 23h15 hervé claude ensuite
une édition spéciale sur les mythes
brejnev dont je vous rappelle que les
obsèques auront sans doute eu lieu lundi
il sera inhumé sur la place rouge et
celle youri andropov l'ancien chef du
kgb qui a été nommé président
la commission des funérailles voilà pour
l'essentiel de cette actualité
extrêmement chargé du 11-novembre 82
j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver
demain à 20h bonne soirée